laughs
okay
right well welcome to uh this meeting of
the standards committee
this is a public meeting being streamed
live
to youtube and via the council's website
the meeting is also being recorded for
the purposes
of the minutes uh being advised that the
live stream
is now up and running if for any reason
the public
can no longer hear or see the meeting
over the live stream
we will adjourn until the connection has
been
uh re-established uh
could i ask at this point for a roll
call of members please
yes of course chair so i'm in the
meeting room today
for the committee we have yourself
councillor armitage's chair and then we
also have councillor ruff
councillor and cliff councillor liggett
councillor hancock
councillor welton and councilman kerry
we also have um
patricia coleman who is our parish
council representative on the committee
and for the officers we have sarah
sernberg
the monitoring officer kevin chilito the
deputy monitoring officer
nicola calva the governance manager
lisa ingram the um legal team manager
and rachel pope and the customer service
manager
and myself and martin derbyshire from um
the governance team
and just for the procedures for the
meeting chair if everyone where possible
can keep their cameras on throughout
and their microphones muted unless they
wish to speak
and adhere to the meeting procedure
rules and
if you experience any technical problems
during the meeting then please let me
know
we'll try and do our best to help you
and voting will be done by a show of
hands which the chair will need
thank you thank you amy for that
uh can we go to item one of that
apologies for absence can the governance
officer please advise if there have been
any apologies for absence technologies
have been received from council ralph's
chair
right are there any other from the floor
okay right uh item two declarations
of interest uh do anybody members have
uh an interested
right item three minutes of the last
meeting
and we agree the minutes of the last
meeting were a true
and accurate record uh whatever
proposer and a second please
i'm happy to move them chair what do i
was saying
happened to them right yes
okay thank you for that
uh could we have a vote of that show of
hands please
all those in favor
again that's all in favor for the
minutes
thank you right item four
is the uh local government and social
care ombudsman
annual review report and
rachel pope customer service manager
is going to present it so over to you
rachel
thank you councillor armitage um first
of all
um there is a slight delay on this
report you'd normally get this
during june time but obviously due to
covid this year
the ombudsman closed for a while and
this
is why um it didn't come to us until
july
and they have put in their report as
well that
they didn't know whether to present it
to us because obviously with the
councils
going through such a difficult year but
they felt it important that obviously we
still
look at our complaints see if there's
any learning from them
see if there's any complaints being
upheld an email administration
uh you know been taken place
so they did still see fit to issue the
report to the authority
which we welcomed of course now before
anybody can go to the local government
ombudsman
they do have to go through the council's
complaints procedure first
so there is a formal stage and then an
internal review
stage which is a bit like of an appeal
after that
if the company resident business is
still dissatisfied with the outcome of
their complaint
then they do have the right to go to the
local government ombudsman
the ombudsman will then review their
case
and they will ask the authority for the
documentation
surrounding the complaint and then they
will take their
view with regards to whether uh they
feel the council has acted fairly
um and in just with the overall
complaint
it may be that they are uphold a
complaint
if they feel there's been an injustice
or they feel that the authority has been
unfair um and
they will stipulate that then that can
um create a fine for the authority
so we have one of these annually and as
i say residents can take their
complaints
to the lga once they've been through the
complaints policy of the councils
we regularly review the complaints
policy with the council and it has
undergone a recent review
to ensure that we are working to best
practice
um and obviously in current guidelines
and all staff have
regular training um on how to deal with
corporate complaints and lessons learned
and things like that on an annual basis
all management team and senior
management team as well are due to
go on some further training directly
with the local government ombudsman
after this christmas um early
next year to again ensure that we are
working to best practice
so the report from the findings of
so from the first 2019-2020 april 2019
to 2020
i'm pleased to say that there was no
complaints
upheld so they would feel that any
inquiries that they have got
um on behalf of residences um
that they do feel that they have been
dealt with uh
fairly um and there was either return
back for a local resolution not taught
how
and feel that the counsellors dealt with
all the inquiries they received whether
investigated or not fairly
thank you does anybody have any
questions
yeah i can't see any indications from
members oh apologies i can see uh
patricia coleman indicating a wish to
speak to
you're muted
looking at page 13 we're talking is at
the top it says that the nine percent of
complaints we investigated were upheld
but the total number of k of of the
complaints that they investigated were
two
now that's compared to 45 in similar
authorities
now what you do if you presented small
numbers as a percentage is it distorts
the impression of the percentage you
know it might
so come what i mean i know it's not you
haven't produced this report
but but it's oh perhaps you have i don't
know but i think that
the numbers involved might just you know
put some perspective on it
yeah so what what it's saying when you
look at appendices 2
and the no percent of the complaints
that they investigated were upheld so
it's saying that out of the ones we
got if you look at the excel spreadsheet
um
the enquiries the ombudsman received in
relation
purely to northeast six
now the if you look at those on the
bottom one
um the reference number that ends in
zero
three six and we've just received
information from that the draft decision
and so that's not going to be upheld
either but that's the enquiries overall
that they've received
on the decisions they've received on the
second element of the excel spreadsheet
that's the overall decisions they've
made um
now the first one on there this is where
the
numbers may vary what ends in 247
that inquiry came in actually the year
before it's just the ombudsman didn't
make the decision
um until april but obviously it still
has to be declared
but on the appendix 2 where you're
saying there's no percent
where they're 45 is it's saying it
compares to an average of 45 percent
in similar authorities so it's not just
northeast it's looking
on par across various whether it be
borrowers or districts
and we've got no percent where other
people have got 45
but that is across a whole i've took an
indication for you from similar
authorities
so for example um within
i purely looked in the um derbyshire
so what's in obviously our own community
so bulls over had one upheld um on that
same year
the obviously a county council for
example had 19 uphold what they are a
county
they're not a district or a borough so
you would expect them to have a slightly
increased perhaps erie walsh
chesterfield and high peak
they got no detailed investigations
there so again i'm not quite sure why
that was whether
you know um they didn't want the the
report or for whatever reasons that
perhaps not had no cases referred
um you know that that could be the
reason there and then derby city
had seven upheld there
across uh councils of that size that's
all it's not sigma
solely northeast i realize it's nothing
to do with northeast i'm saying that the
comparative figure
can be wildly distorted by using
percentages
rather than just say an average of five
you know what i mean yeah i mean not to
45 percent looks
absolutely brilliant and i'm sure you've
done you know northeastern performed
very well
it's just the distorting if they're only
playing with small numbers
which it sounds as though they are to
actually present anything as a
percentage just
distort is a distortion or it can lead
to misunderstanding
at first reading that's that's all i
accept what you're saying in
northeastern well yeah i mean the point
is as well you know i mean it's fair to
say in an ideal world any authority
wouldn't want any complaints going to
the local government ombudsman
but it's nice to know that there is an
independent there that if there is been
any maladministration then it puts us
right but
the positive of this is that you know as
like last year none have been upheld
so the authority must be doing something
right
okay thank you thank you
any more questions
no okay well
we'll move on then to uh item five
and the committee for standards in
public life questionnaire
and i'll ask sarah if she would uh
present the report
apologies to interrupt chair you do have
a recommendation on the report that's
just taken so there's a vote required
for 6.1 on page 9 of the pack that the
standards committee received the annual
review letter of the local
government and social care ombudsman and
notes the outcomes in the report
right i understood it was to be noted
never mind uh career a proposal and a
second of them
i'm happy to move
okay could we have a show of hands
please
that's all in favor thank you
thank you right we moved out
uh to item five the committee for
standards
in public life you know uh and the
uh office present the report is uh
sarah sternberg
thank you chair last year the committee
for standards in public life reviewed
the local government ethical framework
and issued a rather large report which
this committee considered
the report made recommendations some of
which were about good practice
and which did not require any
legislative change
for example you've already seen the
lga's model draft code
and they've consulted us on it
the committee for standards in public
knowledge it is a bit of a mouthful
has now followed this up with a
questionnaire asking for progress on
introducing this good practice
what you've got in your papers is the
questions they've asked
together with a suggested response from
me but it isn't there for you to confirm
to change as you wish and i was intended
to go through each question
chair that's what members would like
board members like that or not
you've all seen it so you should have
done
it's a good idea i i'd be happy for
sarah to go through chair if that's
if everyone's agreeable okay then
over to you sarah thanks chair the first
question is about
having um prohibitions on bullying and
harassment in
the codes of conduct and i've set out
there that in fact
although the district council doesn't
specifically include bullying and
harassment
there are other provisions that you
could handle used to handle any such
allegation
we're relying on the model code
bringing that back to you and making
some adjustments from that
to include specific reference to
bullying however i've also made the
point there in relation to parish
councils
where to be honest bullying is more of
an issue than it is at district level
or allegations are more of an issue than
they are at district level
um that parish councils have a wide
variety of different kinds of codes of
conduct
um some are as brief as just quoting the
nolan principles and that
is their code of conduct so
that standardization coming from a model
code
would greatly enable us to make sure
that the parish councils too
have harassment and bullying in their
codes of conduct
okay any questions
okay well we'll move on now uh to
item six apologies chad i think council
liggett was indicating her wish to speak
yeah i all i wanted to say was i think
that is extremely important sarah that
it it does go in the code of content of
parish councils
the anti-bullying very important
yeah thank you yeah and chair i agree
absolutely um and as soon as we got
something we can send to the parish
council saying this is the model code
it includes all these things and you
should be following it the better
but we have to wait for the lga for that
right if a mic chair there's about
12 questions i was going to go through
some of them not in any detail at all
if i could just go on yeah yeah the
second one
is about requiring councillors to comply
with any formal standards investigation
and prohibiting trivial or malicious
allegations by councillors
we have currently nothing about the
second part in the uh
in the code of conduct the first part is
very interesting it's not an issue we've
had in this authority because
investigations have been very few and
far between
and we haven't hit any problems of
cooperation
but it's on a recent webinar some
external lawyers were talking about
having had that problem when acting for
a council dealing with a complaint it
does enable
the council to say that it's second
breach the code of conduct because they
breached it whatever they did the first
time
and the second time they breached it by
not cooperating
so i think it's a good idea but again
i'm saying we'd look to the lga model
codes
to include that the third
question is um reviewing the
code of conduct each year and regularly
seeking where possible the views of the
public community organizations
and neighboring authorities we certainly
regularly review the code
we've never sought the views of any
external bodies or the public
it's an interesting one because this is
about yourselves
complying with the ethical framework and
i'm not quite
sure um how the public particularly
would be interested in that
having a lot of years ago done done
series of questions for the citizens
panel
i got a very poor response people
weren't interested apart from those who
said everybody's corrupt
so it's an interesting one and one for
us to discuss in the future
i think uh
number four about the code being readily
accessible well it is it's on the
website
and can be accessed from ipads etcetera
number five gives the hospitality
register
updating it at once at least once a
corner caught on publishing it
publication is waiting for the final
stage of mod.carb
because it will be automatically
published as part of that
software system that's the committee's
papers software system
updating it goes on is an ongoing thing
people add to the gifts of hospitality
registers
they make applications this committee
reviews it once a year
and generally we do find there are very
few entries
moving on question six clear and
straightforward public interest tests
against which allegations are filtered
we do have a complaints process which
sets out all the
um decisions that have to be made and
how they will be made
we could review it but it does include a
public interest test particularly in
relation
to investigations whether they are in
the public interest
you tend to find that every complainant
wants to have their
complaint fully investigated but
majority of the time that is not merited
merited in the public interest it's not
in the public interest to do so
hence the document hence the
explanations in there about what is
considered
uh seven access to at least two
independent persons
we have always done sue save where there
is a vacancy
eight and an independent person should
be consulted
whereas to whether in uh sorry i'll slow
down
an independent person should be
consulted as to whether to undertake a
formal investigation on an allegation
the independent person in this authority
is consulted at every stage from the
point at which we get the complaint
onwards so we comply with that in any
event
nine is about publishing a decision
following a full investigation
again it's not an issue we've had in
this authority
it's so it's academic to us but i do
intend to bring a format
to the next standards committee for such
a publication
um so that we've got something agreed
should it arise
this is only investigations this is only
complaints which go through to a full
investigation
irrespective of the outcome so anything
less than that
at this stage we wouldn't be publishing
um straightforward number 10
straightforward and accessible guidance
we have the complaints procedure in
place
um and then number 11 is an interesting
one
they say that complaints essentially by
the clerk
at a parish council should be made by
the chair of the council
this is i i think this is problematic
that the complaint could be against the
chair
so i don't know how it quite works in
that case also i got issues with
whether or not the clerk can actually
make the um complaint in their own right
because i believe they should be able to
down in irrespect to number 11.
and number 12 is about monitoring
officer providing advice support and
management of
investigations etc in with regard to
alleged breaches to parish councils
we do do that as far as is possible as
far as resources allow
so we administer the um actual process
for dealing with the complaints in any
event but we also try to advise and
support parish councils where we can
thank you chair oh no there's some more
i thought i'd finished
um conflicts of interest
it's not been an issue for us in
standards investigations
and number 14 councils report separate
bodies they've set up
this is about companies um
i am reviewing the annual governance
statement and i've actually got a
deadline of
31st march next year to do it it's a bit
of a difficult one with companies
because you've got two different regimes
colliding when you have council
directors etc
and you've got the conflict between the
local government legislation and the
companies legislation
so it's a difficult one to work through
and basically that's what i've said
in the comment senior officers should
meet regularly with political group
leaders or group whips to discuss
standards issues
this happens more of an ad hoc basis but
it does happen
we meet as necessary and i've never
found any barrier to meeting
either i think i really have finished at
that point but
if there are any questions or if i uh
mumbled something please let me know and
i'll repeat it
council hancock absolutely welton are
indicating
thank you sir it's just a query because
i do know it happens
um why are we making no comment in
regards prohibiting trivial or malicious
allegations
by councillors um
you can add a comment um i do think
every time you look at these things as
you know you you think of extra things
i do think you're right i do think we
should be adding in something about
trivial
uh malicious because ultimately there's
a cost to it in time if nothing else
isn't it
absolutely um i can certainly
irrespectively well something to the to
the questionnaire on that but i will
also think about it in terms of bringing
something to you
as a committee to look at because you
will need some criteria for that
to act too and on the other point
i've forgotten which one it was now the
one about the clerk was it question 12.
um question 11. yeah full
fully agree i think the clock needs to
have the ability to go direct in their
own right
um it's we can't we can't bypass them
at all so yeah but apart from that one
issue spot on i think it's a brilliant
piece of work
any more questions i think councilwelter
wanted to
uh yes just to support councillor
hancock on malicious allegations
because they can i think my field goal
is is that they can be used mischief
in mischief as a tool as it were as part
of the
political bear pit so yes i think if you
now use some criteria let's look at some
draft criteria
i just like different point on 11 about
um
the clerk's ability to go make a
complaint himself i mean people do fall
out with their clerks
um you know i think we are aware on two
situations over the past few years
um i if it's a member i'd much rather
that
rather than share where there is a
parish council leader
that the parish council leader makes
that decision makes that um
makes that complaint rather than the
chair
but yeah actually i can add that in if
members want it yeah where yeah where
there is
where there is a leader yeah yeah
yep
okay okay any more questions
do we did take a vote on this chair uh
sarah probably a good idea because i'm
going to be submitting it to the
committee of science and public life
okay so all those in favor today
a show of hands
that's everyone voting for chair
thank you right uh
item six review of the constitution
part three uh and i think uh nicola is
going to
present this over to you thank you chair
um so this is your regular report that
comes to each meeting this is part three
so that's the third time that we've
brought a report to you
on review issues this year um the review
plan is set out in the report
at 1.3 um you've got appendices attached
which highlight the three areas that are
being brought for your consideration
today
those three areas are the jcg terms of
reference
the calling of key decisions and the
delegation scheme in relation to
independent persons
um so chair it would be usual for the
committee to take each
of those areas in turn for discussion
are you happy for me to lead the members
through that
yes yes um so the first item
uh to be discussed today is the jcg
terms of reference
so these have been reviewed um and no
suggested changes are being put forward
bar from housekeeping matters such as
removal of the reference
to the ceo
do members have any questions
you have cancer hancock indicating china
uh i think the chair is frozen housing
by the law is
[Laughter]
it's actually in regard to an issue
that's not actually up for change
on item 3.3 um it concerns me that there
seems to be no representation for any
employees who
aren't members of a union
and should we actually have have a
provision for
an elected member of staff to to
sit on to represent the employees along
with those
if i might help chair yes yes
there is a separate employee liaison
committee
that is set up to get the comments and
and
inform officers who are not part of a
formal recognized union
so that happens in parallel if you like
on an on an informal but regular basis
how do they contribute then because
there's no
there's no provision in here for that to
happen
unless i've missed it no no no this is
the jcg so this is dealing with the
collective agreement with the unions
in addition and in parallel we have an
employee liaison
group that meets members and
representatives of the workforce who
aren't in the unions
they would make suggestions the officers
will pick them up and feed them into the
system from that
right so come through the offices
there are no indications from members
for questions that item
the the next item for discussion today
is the calling in of key decisions
um so this is attached as appendix 3
within your
pack um there is an intention to do a
planned review of delegated decisions
and the procedures that we
that we take um during january and
february
so this has been brought to you today
for you
to have a look at to understand what's
existing in place and to offer
any comments that can be taken into
consideration as part of that review
prior to it being brought back to a
future meeting
any comments
um there are no members indicating chair
okay
um sorry the final um element of that
report
is the delegation scheme so that is uh
the specific um item that was taken to
you council
um show me a moment i will read it out
to you
if i can find it on my screen which has
disappeared off so this is the this is
the
item that was considered at november
council um
for the change with the monitoring
officers
delegations in regard to employing
independent persons
right do you want to comment on this
david i can believe he did at the
meeting i i did but sarah actually
answered my question so
uh i i was happy after that all right
i'm glad you're happy okay
right okay uh
shall we go to item seven then
apologies chair we just need uh the
committee to approve
those uh items for review ready to go
into the report to council
yeah i could have a a proposal and a
sector please
we've got uh councillor heather liggett
and councillor david hancock
okay we'll take a vote then all those in
favor please show
all members are voting in favor chair
thank you
item seven then complaints update sarah
could you give her the verbal report
please i want to
share yes during the course of the
corporate year so that's from january
the first we've received 14 complaints
eight of which related to parish
councils and six of which related to
district councillors
eight have been closed with no further
action and we have six
ongoing but they are very near to
completion as well
thank you okay uh
well item eight then is the work program
uh uh could uh amy give us a rundown on
it please
yes chair um your work program for the
remainder of the
municipal year is set out on page 33 in
your packs so you've got
two meetings left for this year um
so the items due to come to you is set
out there so it's just
um please let me know if you want to
make any changes or amend anything
is there anything that anybody would
like to
add or immediately syndicating
yeah what's happened to the video thing
that was being reviewed about the
editing of the videos
that was supposed to be going on here
wasn't it yes if i might say
absolutely this is to come to your next
meeting
um yes it should be added to it it's a
protocol
for you difficult
anything else that we that's pressing
let's put it like that
moments are indicating their wish to
speak sure
okay right item nine
urgent business i have no urgent items
myself
that's anybody else any urgent items to
discuss
nothing from members chair right
the date of the next schedule meeting is
uh wednesday the 24th of february
so we've been to a new year
and on that note i would like to thank
you all for your attendance
uh and thank the officers for the work
that they've done
and to wish you all a merry christmas
and have a good one
and we'll see you all hopefully in the
new year
okay i declare the meeting
you